I'm Amanda and I live yoga this is your
at-home yoga core workout so Amanda's
gonna run me through this okay we're
gonna be doing gonna start off and
downward facing dog okay we'll watch
this your right leg up into the set
we're gonna bring the knee into the nose
exhale inhale reach it back out exhale
right knee to right tricep inhale reach
it out exhale right knee left tricep
inhale reach that we're gonna do that
three more times reach it back out bend
your knee open the hip stick and stretch
through the psoas and then replace that
foot and then you switch to the left
once you do that I'll show you something
else okay exciting let's give it a shot
so come into downward facing dog right
leg up into the sky bring me into nose
reach it back out bring right knee to
right tricep reach it back out where you
need to left triceps
take it across sake reach it back out
two more times - like that reached out
downward-facing dog shoulders back
take the right leg up into the sky bend
your knees open your head there you go
he's slowly really stuff like them then
we're going to switch on to the left
side but if you want to take it up a
notch downward-facing dog will start
their right leg up into the sky and
bring right knee to right tricep right
elbow down to the wrist meet back up to
the elbow down to the wrist back up the
elbow down to the wrist back up to the
elbow then shoot it to the left here you
go down to the wrist up to the elbow
down to the wrist back to that
three-legged down dog
foot comes down you just dropped out I
like that a lot
it's good what else yeah you come back
into your downward facing dog
and taking me to nuts then drop it down
bring it into the chest just like that
and then you take it to the right elbow
to the left back to the right back to
the left back to the right back to the
left then you're gonna come into a plank
pose and you just you bend your right
knee bend your left so really isolating
the obliques here which is super
important for any low back health you
could do that a few times and just until
so tired okay so bring your knee into
your nose drop it down towards the mat
back up into the chest down to the mat
back up into the chest one more time fix
down to the mat back up to the chest to
the right elbow to the left to the right
elbow to the left right left step to
plank and then just bend your right knee
bend your left knee
then right knee then
you do that till tired till exhaustion
yeah let's fill each one bar every time
you move your legs everything yeah this
is really good core workout thank you
well to recap guys we did a variation of
plank poses downward dog and your knee
is going to nose to chest and to either
tricep the whole point of this is to
marry it and so you're constantly
incorporating all areas of the core and
you get some side benefits with other
and muscle groups as well really
different but very good core workout
make sure to subscribe so you don't miss
out on any other fighting weight
episodes